we have learned about the forthcoming
testimony of the former deputy national
security adviser to donald trump in
front of the january 6 trump riot
committee this is a really really big
deal now i know many of you are
wondering the same thing i'm wondering
is this
witness the one that donald trump tried
to call
in order to tamper with to influence his
forthcoming testimony we don't know the
answer to that but we'll get back to
that in a moment
first on cnn former trump national
security council official will testify
at thursday's january 16th hearing this
is not like some intern or coffee boy
this is the deputy national security
advisor and in fact it's widely known
that
the deputy national security adviser is
often the person really running the
national security council who's
uh who becomes sort of the intermediary
between the security council the
national security adviser and everybody
else matthew pottinger is his name he
served on trump's nsc before resigning
in the aftermath of january 6th there is
a prime time hearing on thursday night
my intent like joe biden says my intent
is to cover it baby permitting uh he
will testify publicly at thursday's
primetime hearing
pottinger is slated to appear alongside
former trump white house aide sarah
matthews who is believed to have quite
uh uh
extreme or uh nuanced nuance both really
insights into the trump white house cnn
previously reported that matthews who
was deputy press secretary until
resigning shortly after january 6 was
expected to testify publicly when she
resigned matthew said she was honored to
serve in trump's administration but was
deeply disturbed by what she saw
pottinger trump's deputy national
security adviser stepped down in
response to trump's reaction to his
supporters breaching the u s capital
he told people there was very little for
him to consider a spokesperson for the
committee has declined to comment
we are going to see
some very very real stuff on what is
right now the final scheduled hearing
from the january 6 trump riot committee
the headline here
dramatically understates who matthew
pottinger was it simply says national
security council official as i said
we're talking here about the principle
deputy national security advisor
front row
to everything that was going on in that
extremely high level organization group
committee whatever you want to call it
now there are a few things that are
going to happen first of all is the
question
did donald trump call you to try to talk
to you about this testimony and we don't
know the answer to that we know pearl is
cheney that donald trump tried to call
some forthcoming witness it may be
matthew pottinger it may not hopefully
members of congress on the committee ask
that question on thursday and we will
get an answer number two
trump will probably attempt the typical
smear campaign that he does when people
testify
and when people become disgruntled or
whatever term you want to use
uh he will say this was not a
particularly good employee he wasn't
particularly bright and on and on and on
and of course there are two different
issues with that number one trump says
it about everyone who has something
negative to say about him that's number
one and of course number two
trump ran on i know how to hire people
and the best people i can tell who's
good and who's not good i can tell who's
smart not smart good at a job
and
individual after individual who is left
we're talking about rex tillerson we're
talking about john bolton it's a very
long list cassidy hutchinson more
recently in terms of the uh witnesses in
this committee trump attacks them and
says they weren't smart and all these
different things well you hired him
you hired him and you said your hiring
was really the best thing that you did
now
what happens after the committee is done
we don't know the answer to that there
is
you know the the
the question continues to be
will merrick garland and the department
of justice charge anyone based on what
was learned in this committee we don't
know the answer to that i think that
there are two different ways to look at
this one if you came to me and you said
sir
obama right uh do you have any reason to
believe merrick garland plans to charge
people based on this committee i would
say no i have no reason to believe that
the only thing we've heard is the doj is
paying attention to the committee
hearings okay but we have seen no
evidence that garland is willing to do
what would be admittedly very difficult
in charging some of these former
officials on the other hand
it is true
that it takes a while to put cases
together and it's completely plausible
realistic
that if indeed the doj learned about
possible crimes from watching the
committee hearings and they started
investigations only when the committee
hearings took place
it's completely plausible that it would
take a couple to a few months to put
together a case and investigate whether
there are charges they're confident they
could get a guilty verdict on so the
timing is not really the issue for me
it's reasonable that they hear about
something in june
and they might charge in october or
november or december that the timeline
isn't really the concern the concern is
it seems as though there's kind of a
meekness
with regard to even really seriously
considering charging these people
up to and including donald trump and
that's what makes me wonder
is it just they're putting cases
together or is it there's no real
interest and willingness to actually do
what would be very difficult but would
be the right thing to do if that's where
the facts point let me know what you
think is taking place you can find me on
twitter at d pacman i also want to
remind you next tuesday one week from
today is the next david pakman show
viewer town hall these are you know we
do the calls on the friday show but we
don't have that much time for it usually
it's about 20 25 minutes
next tuesday 6 p.m eastern time 3 p.m
pacific us of course for our friends in
europe it'll be you know like midnight
um we're going to be opening up the
phone lines and we will be taking an
hour to an hour and a half of calls
everybody is welcome to call in if you
want to watch here's the sort of key
thing
it will only air
on the pacman live youtube channel it
won't be on the main youtube channel the
one with the roughly 1.5 million
subscribers it won't be on twitch it
won't be on facebook we will only be
streaming the town hall on the pacman
live youtube channel everybody can watch
everybody can participate and yes if you
are a website member you will get
priority access to participate in the
town hall all right more about that as
we get closer
one of our sponsors today is bluechew a
unique online service delivering the
same active ingredients as viagra and
cialis in a chewable form and at a
fraction of the cost and they're giving
my audience an entire month supply for
free so if you think you could benefit
from an extra boost of confidence
when it's time
all you have to do is take a short quiz
on their website a licensed doctor
approves your prescription the
medication comes straight to your home
within days in a discreet package no
driving around to the doctor's office or
the pharmacy no waiting around no
awkward conversations with your doctor
all of blue chews tablets are made in
the usa the entire process is just a few
clicks
go to bluechew.com the link is
underneath this video they'll give you
an entire month's supply for free when
you use the promo code pacman all you
have to do is pay five dollars shipping